welcome back to the games would stage
here at e3 2016 tomorrow and I are
honored to be joined by yamaguchi-san
from Polyphony Digital to talk about GT
sport this is Gran Turismo debut on the
PlayStation 4 how is it going to be
different what would the big challenges
are bringing it to a new console places
for the holiday with answer is no God
was also a mosquito so no chi Hudson II
might swoon with Scott Scotty boom why
you don't know challenge the article
sweet muah DOTA 2's ahsoka que todas me
oh no come Capri station fo de skoura
hase mentoring grantees moto akuto day
boo Corrigan Rita echo toga mejor de
carros Tara so Cullen a boon an
appreciation for the two decided to
connect showed up and is net no no day
muwah coxinha let's go eat and a skirt
amo oh no soitec I mucho who stole a
stud crius take my processor surrogate I
hand this to me so being on the
PlayStation 4 for the first time you
know we had these objectives that we set
very high for ourselves and that we had
high expectations that we can get a lot
of those things done but you know to
actually go through that process of you
know reaching those objectives was a was
a lot of work for us fans have been they
they really want the dynamic weather day
tonight cycle can you explain the
reasons why they're not present on the
phone I look at you I by dynamic ena
otherwise I don't think Hank atoka I
don't I chicken Hinkle what she t voy a
keycode cotton pillow so you got a
second cowhide and cuts on the sofa it
on a moto moto dynamic us at OPA dynamic
writing the table over GTA 5 OCT 6th
Hajime Tabata nan desu nee nee na na
sono Mehdi todo de merito mondo grass
ooh yakitate a day concavity mera toh
hoga oketo Johan de un stands nay an
undead Sunday Milito tui na nanika to
youto meso graphics denton okorie tiga
Sebastian DCO sequani Giotto mota certo
hey sorry Oliva pray yoga gisenyi
suprema you got autophagy go to Kyoto
party no era video instead
there's no jikan niver chicana Henkes
night are you attend kahin caseinate you
in game design insta hoga mahogany game
design adequacy pray I entered to meet I
can ejaculate the photo camera at the
dance none of the concave us all started
booties so um you know the dynamic
weather changes and lighting changes was
something that we originally started in
Gran Turismo 5 and 6 and you know having
done all that we really discovered what
are the advantages and disadvantages of
having that system in there and you know
my ultimate decision was that you know
the disadvantage is outweighed the
advantages and that's because you know
when you look at the overall quality of
the graphics you know having that system
they're really drops the quality quite a
bit so we after you know making the
considerations you know I decided that
you know it would be better in terms of
both game design and experience if the
players are able to set the time of day
and set the weather before the race and
the conditions are maintained you know
throughout the race so fans of the
series obviously gran turismo is a huge
huge racing series they used to having
the releases in the form of a prologue
than a numbered entry in the title what
is why did you try to go for a spin off
like sport a lot of people might be
thinking it's kind of unusual like it
maybe it's it's a lesser game because
it's not gran turismo number 7 or
whatever is so what's the thinking
behind using focusing on spore no fun
like anybody's pharmaceutics on that
swiss mortality no yeah buddy career
which titles to a record imagine on a
very current road oh you got a number
the title the daily mean I've told you
guys a little now they are quite a
spin-off title Medina McGraw is most
posted on my own RX cotati sofa hi
unregister so Tiger no photo you don't
nest on each color in there my each kind
of the semester of story much still
grandissimo sports margt 7 gratis 170
the moment ago says Karen I'm
disney dae na SZI buco God and 7 de una
cosa post oska takato Yuto Oh No cono
gran turismo sports car baklava atarashi
eSports modo to you no prima donna
resume no se quedo carry on a photo into
ratio to state a ESO no tameni mas
sports da skatin miss me descara
beaucoup de la di da ba grant a spoon
one chorus exuma diga mascot no gran
turismo no generation datos ruto Cano
gran turismo sports car hidamari sekai
de nova oh no grunting some wine I no
okina in your base on day my 7th a
tomato Captain de como disse vicious
olika rc3 cry okay now Jamie not a seat
acrid amo ah no esposo tied to the car
and sob osito you honey oh wait Anderson
demo- answer when you are earrin de su
casa bond aveo katakana pick us
so I actually get this question I asked
a lot so it's a great opportunity to
talk about it now we actually could have
called it seven and the reason why we
decided to go with sport instead is
because the major focus of me on this
title is that we're starting this new
sports mode that's really going to sort
of change the racing world and if you
consider your gran turismo one through
six as sort of the first arrow or the
first generation of Gran Turismo you
know from starting from sport we're
really entering this new era and that's
why it mean when I really considered it
you know it seemed better to actually
call it granturismo sport been having an
another title or of the Gran Turismo
number series and you know we could have
easily called it 70 has all the features
it has a size of a full-sized game and
you know when people have asked me over
and over again this same question and
you know I I went back and thought about
it was like yeah you know I could have
called it seven it would have been easy
to do so yeah but you know that was the
reasoning behind the naming of the title
was there a discussion of taking Gran
Turismo and presenting like a new flavor
on it obviously your compare biggest
competitor is Forza and Microsoft have a
straight simulation racing game and to
complement that they've created this
almost like festival style rarely
experienced and was there ever a
discussion about maybe taking a spin off
doing a spin-off and maybe perhaps even
sport becoming that kind of title I know
my gran turismo no mo flava Tino's piety
sala de ano ano each monkey the computer
to say a fortune re-mose nemesi me so no
carrera y carrera my simulation racing
game would do you know you are suggested
concarneau ma a latino festival matana
I was being off thats good day then I
know Artemis oh no my glasses good sport
of scrutiny no atmosphere off no titles
cloak amita an idea SI saket oh stop 80
grand terrace Novotny mas Pitino data
Sveta no koto oh poor ago indiscernible
nastassja yo no kana let's go Tony
Moreno sutoko text and a sunny vizcarra
gran turismo spin-off started over
tomorrow to go to AA a.d na na na socio
to grantees madhavan aku not this mode
you know in for grant trees mom you know
all the data all the code that goes into
the title is really developed by the 200
or more staff that we have working
straight out of Japan so you know it's
really unthinkable for gran turismo that
we would have somebody else make a
spin-off title for example because then
it wouldn't be GT anymore ok how do you
maintain working on this game for this
series for so long how do you maintain a
passion like is it just literally less
intense passion for simulation racing
and cars or how do you how do you keep
that drive to create new games over and
over again without kind of diversifying
what they are too much because the Gran
Turismo that we have now is very much
the lineage back to the originals is
clear like you're not going too far away
usually people when they work on
something this menu for this long they
try and reinvent it in different ways
but gran turismo has largely stayed the
same and the modes around it have kind
of changed somewhat how do you maintain
the passion for it and the drive to keep
making it I know what I'll do Uniqua no
one of the game whoa Medina aye aye that
secretes a special key push the
three-way simulation in wayanad oh god
oh my god no buddy who cannot see
develop a teen comedy comedy ano na die
I that's a scary toe-to-toe a nose
michio solitary potosi dostal issue in
de dólares no ta chegando boon do a
present oh no inochi hoco solon so there
are no my daughter motivation cara so
comedy dictated ahsoka hey Tony an open
gran turismo spot so scooter I'd an
amoeba no gravity t 10 coronet an o
Donis kousaka Satan Oh Hattie Iona day
Tagami polyphony des earnest habana
kangan poor Taytay te reo Espada's
Damita di most o locust and eskimo
fasken invoke raha hoon own ego named
can Oh taroko photo empresa y e una de
muchos a toga toga subio co-occur de
para una gran turismo sports mo mag on
cotton aqui gran turismo nan desu kedo
mou-chan and Ezra God de todo su carrera
takato youto amo esta tu Novotny takaya
mucho o motor indiscernible crony de
Gran Turismo na who cannot compensate oh
na naman Chicago to you totally Kakaako
routine on the silk Ortega Auto Tech in
each round escena de Carabas on
Authority you know sort of context i
know not God scarico to deny motivation
are in this me oh no that happens to get
item that the wound is give me so you
know what we were developing you know
granturismo sport we actually did sort
of look back at all the data we still
have in our servers that policy to see
you know what what was our mindset when
we started creating the first gran
turismo and you know looking at all this
data and looking at all this information
we you know obviously we have had the
same target for you throughout the
entire series over the years and gran
turismo sport is undoubtedly gran
turismo and I think it's because you
know we've always aimed for a very high
level in our development um you know
what makes gran turismo different from
you know other competitor titles out
there is really that you know that
consistent pursuit of you know the
highest quality possible and you know
we've never strayed from that from that
from that objective I think that that
motivation to reach that quality level
is what we
sets us apart for driving same fans how
deep does the simulation go so no
driving simulation to store assimilation
to come at the sky takuma da whoa so the
next at sunoco totes titanius quedo I
know Scott Savannah come kind of Gran
Turismo sports to you nevah your i do at
how the couana malish english murrieta
to stay it's catera godiva knocked a
resume today's game of press resto toca
a cemetery mountains destiny an antique
room at Ted intentional tanoshinde wrote
of an antec room out there it's kashima
on the road to go totes Toyota minutes
good day imissu heyday dojin e naught is
a mnemonic I showed up ready granata
Moscato uh no not 80 degree baccarin
discard mo ana paulanos quick remedy mo
re ba mosoku Harrison cod mo prima donna
gran turismo Inc Roberto hora con ESA's
any Krav Maga intend a query on not
Terran dismay takara nah no Manos coq au
vin tangas oh so nice Tove a note mo ano
saikano driving attacking a decree Oni
driving the physics machine customs ok
so I think there's two things you know
this version of Gran Turismo wasn't
really developed just for the hardcore
ways in simulator fan you know we really
went to great lengths to cater to the
first time you know players to racing
games and also first time drivers was
never driven a real car before you know
we really wanted these people to kind of
experience you know how fun it is to
drive a car and how beautiful cars are
we wanted them to that's the experience
that we wanted them to have so you know
when you play the actual the demo we
have on the show floor today you know
you can tell when you first get into the
cars whether it be a very low powered
car or a very high-powered core you know
you have a natural sense of driving
that's much much users and you would
expect from a simulator it's you know
and that's something that you know goes
to the level where even somebody who
when when somebody who's very good at
driving drives
car will still have that natural feel
well thank you so much for joining us
when does GT sport release dt sports on
Diddy's white so yesterday I got some
actual indefinite it's due to release
mid-november doesn't thank you so much
for joining us for more coverage of this
year's e3 of course make sure you stay
tuned to gamespot com you're watching
the game spot stage brought to you by
airheads